[Musique]
salut à tous c'est Pierre vous êtes bien
sur envergure épisode five star on va
parler d'un pivot qui est grand qui joue
maintenant pour
et pour se faire j'ai Lucas avec moi et
Mathias salut Lucas salut Mathias salut
les gar salut excuse-moiés c'est pas
graveas on y va le nouveau pivot
d'Indiana de cette année c'est un
certain kware kare on aime bien parce
que déjà il y a une petite particularité
dans le prénom
ouais il y a l'apostrophe en plein
milieu du prénom quoi et ça on
adore alors du coup kelware né en 2004
donc 19 ans il est en 2e année
universitaire et c'est àintérieur 2
M1 le fameux seven footer pour 104 kg
c'est un gars qui qui grandit dans
l'Arkansas et qui fait toute sa période
lycée dans l'arcansas dans son lycée de
North Little Rock High
School rapidement ça devient un gros
gros prospect aux US avec une vraie hype
il a le parcours classique de tous ces
gars qui qui ont une grosse côte que le
Jordan Brand classique le nikop Smit le
McDonald de l'American et et en 2022 il
participe aussi en championnat
d'Amérique U18 qui va remporter avec la
team USC h et donc ensuite il y a donc
le début de son année sa première année
universitaire recrue 5 étoiles il refuse
plusieurs gros programmes et aussi une
belle offre financière de la part de
l'overtime
élite pour euh s'engager avec euh les
DUGS d'Oregon et
euh malheureusement c'est une première
saison qui va pas très bien se passer
pour lui il va disparaître très
rapidement des MCK draraf et cetera et
puis il va se retrouver avec euh 16
minutes de moyenne euh à peine 7 points
de moyenne et cetera par match et donc
résultat pas de draft et une demande de
transfert à la fin de la saison qu' le
verra se diriger vers l'Indiana chez les
wziers qui cherchait justement un
remplaçant de 1 Jackson Davis qui est
parti chez les Warriors
exactement donc partie chez les wers de
Mike Woodson si je dis pas de bêtises
ouais comment ça joue cette année
Indiana dans quel contexte il est l'ami
Ker pourquoi il montre enfin son son
potentiel bah alors comme je disais il y
a une place toute trouvée dans la
raquette d'Indiana au côté de Mali Ren
qui a un autre intérieur un peu plus
petit qui qui exc sur le panier et donc
bah Woodson le coach il le met direct
titulaire dans la raquette au poste 5 et
puis puis il occupe tout de suite le
Point d'Encre défensif de son équipe en
apportant toute sa protection d'arsau sa
forte présence au rebond et cetera et
puis là il est déjà en quasi double
double de moyenne avec quasiment direbon
et et carrément 20 % de ses rebond des
rebond de son équipe donc donc il a pris
sa place très rapidement dans cette
équipe de d'Indiana qui cherchait un
nouveau leader et de l'autre côté du
terrain bah W il est aussi très très
intéressant puis il occupe une forte
place dans le système offensif avec 23 %
de usage rate rate donc donc voilà
Indiana s'est trouvé un un nouveau un
nouveau leader euh comment on pourrait
qualifier le le jeu d'Indiana moi
personnellement je trouve c'est un petit
peu old school c'està-dire que c'est
très axé justement depuis trace Jackson
Davis très aé sur les prises de position
à l'intérieur un petit peu comme on
faisait il y a il y a 20 ans dans dans
le basket FIBA estce que on est un peu
toujours dans ce contexte là
avec on l'est toujours on l' un peu
moins que l'année dernière quand même
parce que on avait Jason Davis qui qui
stretchait quasiment pas mais c'est vrai
qu'on est toujours là-dessus on est
beaucoup à la recherche de de
l'intérieur avec W ou Renault mais c'est
quand même un peu plus moderne je trouve
que l'année dernière W il est beaucoup
utilisé pour poser des écrans sur des
shooter autour mais c'est vrai que c'est
un c'est un basket plutôt Schol après il
y a peut-être quelque chose à dire c'est
parler du du comment du playmaking de
cette équipe que je trouve moi sur les
matchs que j'ai vu en tout cas pas
extraordinaire il est pas vraiment super
bien entouré à ce niveau-là je trouve
c'est vrai que Indiana il y a pas de
super super joueur sur le bas courte il
y a xer Johnson qui est un un senior
très expérimenté mais qui est blessé et
du coup il une un petit peu en perte de
en perte de de qualité sur sur ce sur ce
secteur là de son équipe il y a g cups
mais qui est vraiment un freshman et qui
qui fait de son mieux mais c'est un peu
le le souci
d'ingana très clairement Mathias
pourquoi on parle de ce joueur
maintenant pour la draft en 2024 c'est
quoi un peu son son ticket d'entrée euh
pour la NBA qu'est-ce qui fait que les
SCO le regardent bah forcément quand on
parle d'un d'un intérieur de 2 M13 tout
de suite on on pense au au profil de RIM
Runner protecteur qui est recherché par
par les équipes NBA aujourd'hui
euh en plus de ça il a une très bonne
mobilité il bouge très bien et puis il y
a quand même
des un un shoot qui laisse entrevoir une
possibilité de de s'écarter de l'arceau
euh en année une ça ça reste voir en NBA
je sais pas si pourra tout de suite
avoir des minutes surtout que c'est pas
évident pour des joueurs de ce profil de
des RIM Runner on peut penser à Mark
Williams ou clony qui qui ont eu du mal
dans leur première année mais ouais tout
de suite quand on pense à NBA pour lui
c'est pour ce profil de RIM runard sa
mobilité à Oregon é un petit peu mise en
question parfois est-ce que cette année
c'est mieux ou il est c'est plus mis en
valeur peut-être alors à Orgon c'était
compliqué ouais mais je pense que on lui
reprochait plus les efforts que sa que
sa vraie capacité de pouvoir bien bouger
là Indiana il est beaucoup plus mieux
mise en valeur il y a une confiance de
son coach et honnêtement je je trouve
qu'il bouge très bien peut-être pas le
plus gros moteur mais en tout cas
latéralement dans sa mobilité dans à
l'intérieur de la raquette je trouve que
il se débrouille vraiment pas mal et il
est pas en énorme difficulté quand il se
retrouve à à switcher sur un sur un Gard
adverse Lucas je vais te lancer sur Laam
kelel qu'est-ce que pour toi c'est quoi
son critère d'entrée pour la draft
prochaine bah déjà c'est c'est
mensuration physique comme l'a dit
Mathias c'est c'est un se foour qui a
quand même 2 m84 de stunning rich donc
c'est c'est c'est pas rien c'est pas des
mecs qui se baladent dans la rue il a
plus de 2, d'envergure et ça en fait
déjà un protecteur de cercle naturel qui
en plus a les outils à les armes pour
aller vraiment apporter une défense euh
des blocs beaucoup de dissuasion
mais ce qui fait aussi sa force c'est
pour moi c'est ai fait ce qui fait sa
faiblesse c'est que cette mobilité qu'il
a en défense
ça lui coûte beaucoup une fois qu'il
arrive en attaque il est très frê même
si je crois que Matthias tu as dit qu'il
à 105 kg moi je l'ai à je l'ai à
seulement 95 ouais moi aussi c'est la
Doni que j'avais ah je crois que j'ai
pris le le poids sur le site directement
d'ind
et offensivement on sent que que que que
ça lui coûte c'est ces kilos là il a
énormément de mal à faire la différence
dans la raquette même s'il essaye quand
même avec l'pul et cetera
mais ça ça le gêne quand même pas mal et
même en défense on peut voir sur
certains boxouts où il y a des pivots
typiquement bien mature bien Undiz qui
lui font beaucoup de mal donc je dirais
que son ticket d'entrée en NB c'est
qualités physiques c'estes mensurations
aussi sa protection de ser comme tu l'as
dit c'est c'est c'est le RIM Runner
c'est c'est facile de le voir c'est
c'est c'est
extrêmement extrêmement évident donc
donc oui forcément ces qualités de RIM
Runner sont sont sont sont évidentes et
dures à à cacher mais il y a aussi son
côté physique ou moi je me pose des
questions parce que c'est un 2004 c'est
vrai qu'il est jeune il a le temps
encore mais est-ce qu'il va réussir à
rajouter du poids sans perdre ce qui au
final est son ticket
d'entrée à propos de ticket d'entrée il
y a le côté production offensive qui
peut être aussi mise en avant on voit
qu'il a en plus une palette relativement
large c'estàd que comme disait Mathias
c'est un garçon qui est capable de tirer
qui le fait même plutôt bien pour un
pour ce début d'année on y crois ça ou
ou c'est un peu
contextuel je pense que c'est forcément
contextuel contte tenu du fait qu'il est
largement utilisé mais moi honnêtement
il quand même passé de 6 points de
moyenne à 17 points de saison je pense
que ça tombe pas comme ça forcément être
talentueux et et avoir un un vrai talent
offensif pour pour être aussi fort et
puis comme tu le dis il a une vraie
palette technique il est capable de de
sortir des des gros Dung des des hook
plus en finesse même des spin MOV et
puis en plus il est très efficace il a
plus de 60 % de fil gold il a quasiment
80 % au Cercle donc ouais force c'est
pas le joueur qui a le meilleur footwork
il plus technique mais il a vraiment un
beau toucher je trouve et qui lui permet
de se sortir de pas mal de situations
ouais il y a une stade que je trouve
assez impressionnante c'est sur ces les
long de comme on dit où il est à 50 % au
tir avec 44 prises donc on est en début
de saison d'accord mais quand même c'est
vrai que le le trou shooting chez lui
est assez incroyable parce qu'il est
quasiment 66 donc c'est assez fort
effectivement qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir à développer chez lui quelles sont
les craintes qu'on peut légitimement
avoir
Mathias bah je pense que tout de suite
ce qui vient
ce qui vient en tête c'est de développer
son trois points maintenant il en est
conscient je pense
euh c'est c'est un forcément un aspect
de son jeu qui va être ultra important à
l'étage supérieur maintenant moi
j'aimerais bien qui qui qui plutôt qui
s'améliore sur deux autres points
notamment la passe c'est pas un joueur
qui qui a une superbe vision ou en tout
cas qui brille par sa vision du jeu on
le voit trop rarement essayer de faire
le jeu de je sais pas t un kickout quand
il est servi au poste ou ou tenter une
passe sur un cut mais dans une NBA
aujourd'hui qui qui recherche de plus en
plus de de Big qui est capable de
produire sur sur cette ligne statistique
je trouve que c'est un un domaine dans
lequel il doit
progresser sur les progressions à venir
pour que quel est l' existe en NBA je
voulais juste rebondir sur ce que
Mathias a dit sur sur les passes moi je
je je après sur les ce que j'ai vu j'ai
j'ai regardé que cette saison je suis
vraiment pas d'accord sur la passe j'ai
vu un mec de 2 M13 dans une prise à 2 à
0°gr être capable de balancer une passe
à l'autre bout du terrain qui arrive
dans les mains bien bien avec une bonne
trajectoire
euh même si il est pas dans un contexte
où il est là pour pas faire la passe et
créer pour les autres étant donné qu'il
est là pour vraiment se montrer ça se
sent parce que tous les ballons passent
par lui et il y a très peu d'hésitation
dans ces tir on sent qu'il est vraiment
là qu'il a envie de de scorer et cetera
mais sur des flash il y a vraiment des
flashes à la passe et il a un touché tu
as un touché mi-distance tu as un touché
pour pour pour la passe et il l'a
clairement c'est ça qui qui m'a
impressionné avec lui c'est parce que au
début étant donné que il est vraiment il
a pas du tout cette intention là en
postup de comme tu le dis ressortir la
balle à à l'OM libre à zéro mais ça pour
moi c'est pas qui peut pas faire de
passe c'est que pour l'instant le
contexte il est c'est pas ce qu'il veut
faire il il a pas l'intention de faire
la passe mais quand il doit la faire
quand il est prise à deux qu'il est
bloqué il arrive toujours à trouver le
mec seul et à lui faire une bonne passe
qui est impressionnant pour un mec de
cette taille parce que souvent les gars
de cette taille qu'on voit là ok il
bougeent bien ok il court bien mais
souvent ils ont beaucoup de mal à faire
de bonnes passes et et là ça quand même
impressionné sur les sur les matchs que
j'ai vu cette saison Mathias tu es
plutôt comment dire est-ce que tu es
plutôt convaincu par l'argument de Lucas
ou pas non mais après je dis pas qu'il
est pas qu'il est pas capable de le
faire ouais comme il l'a dit moi ce que
je voulais dire c'est surtout que c'est
pas ce qu'il recherche dans un premier
temps h et moi souvent je le enfin sur
les matchs que j'ai vu souvent j'ai trop
vu des tues partenaires seul et et un
Ware qui qui tentait plutôt de de faire
un TR un TR point un un panier ou de
sortir sur un autre coéquipier
qui qui est moins démarqué mais je
trouve qu'il y a pas assez de kickout ou
de de changement de de changement de de
changement d'il et je trouve que c'est
c'est ce que j'aimerais le voir le faire
plus souvent mais je dis pas qu'il est
pas capable de le faire en tout cas euh
au niveau du jeu purement intérieur
qu'est-ce sur quoi on peut s'inquiéter
pour lui par rapport à des choses
simples des fondamentaux d'intérieur
poser des écrans les écrans de retard la
dissuasion euh au Cercle aussi parce que
vous m'avez parlé d'un RIM runnerur
justement et pas d'un RIM protecteur
parce que justement en fait en en terme
de contre il est assez peu efficient
pour le moment il est que à un bloc aidé
par match ce qui n'est pas incroyable
pour un mec de de sa taille qu'est-ce
qu'il y a à creuser là encore Lucas
euh pour moi euh le problème il est
principalement physique
h parce que dès que il a une situation
en défense où il veut aller pour le bloc
par exemple j'ai une action qui me
revient là dans son dernier match contre
je crois que c'est auurn il va pour
faire le contre en deuxème rideau et il
y a simplement l'intérieur de d'oburn
qui se met qui lui fait un box out il
est incapable physiquement d'avoir la
capacité de bouger le gars pour pour
vraiment aller protéger le cercle et
même au niveau des screens c'est ces
screens sont sont peu efficaces parce
que le meneur même si il est
largement plus petit que lui et il peut
le bouger facilement donc pour moi c'est
vraiment ça qui m'inquiète comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure et que c'est c'est
pour moi c'est sa gros sa plus grosse
piste de travail parce que ça l'hicap
dans vraiment beaucoup d'aspects de son
jeu et est-ce qu'on est inquiier par sa
production au contre ou pas du tout
c'est un peu le jeu d'Indiana qui veut
ça aussi
mathas non moi je suis pas forcément
inquiet n pas forcément besoin d'être à
deux trois comptes de moyenne pour
pouvoir être un point dissuadeur au de
paniers s'il y a s'il y a un joueur qui
arrive au CERC il sera forcément capable
de de poser le contre pour moi c'est pas
important si s'il a pas une énorme
moyenne au contre on l'a vu aussi
essayer de partir en drible vu que c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui justement est
fin et plutôt agile assez rapide aussi
vu son le faible poids qu'il a par
contre ça se passe rarement bien est-ce
que ça c'est une piste à creuser ou pas
ouais après je pense pas qu'on lui
demandera beaucoup de de poser le ballon
en NBA clairement euh dans un premier
temps après euh ouais c'est un c'est un
joueur qui qui qui est fin qui a dû
toucher donc je pense que il peut
développer un un un drible mais c'est
pas ce qu'on lui demandera je pense non
mais et puis en plus ce spoiler ça s'est
rarement bien passé à la fin à chaque
fois qu'il qu'il l'a fait donc je pense
pas qu'il va être encouragé dans cette
voielà non plus par que j'ai une image
comme ça qui me revient contre Michigan
où il pense que comme beaucoup
d'intérieur qui peut mener une
contre-attaque mais en fait non c'est
pas très trop possible est-ce que on
peut dire que parce que c'est quand même
un garçon qui a souvent la la balle près
près du cercle en attaque est-ce qu'il a
vraiment ce côté palette ave avec les
les deux mains ou pour l'instant c'est
très axé sur sa main forte la la main
droite moi je l'ai rarement vu dans des
situations où
euh euh il est mis en difficulté sur sa
main droite et il se décale avec
facilité sur sa main gauche après je
j'attends que mathas confirme ça mais je
vois pas une main gauche qui est aussi
dominante que que sa main droite mais
après ça c'est c'est c'est ça viendra
avec le travail je pense et c'est pas
quelque chose qui qui va m'inquiéter en
en en vue de la draft en tout cas est-ce
que Mathias on va parler un petit peu de
de l'attitude euh du du garçon on sait
que il est parti tu l'as dit dans la
présentation il est parti un petit peu
en froid avec l'entraîneur de
deoregon comment ça se passe avec My
Woodson sur le ce début de saison là bah
forcément autant sur le plan individuel
pour W ça se passe bien mais autant sur
le plan collectif ça se passe plutôt
bien aussi donc pour l'instant la la
relation avec son coach elle est bonne
comme tu le disais il était parti de Ron
en froid avec son coach qui qui qui
avait été déçu avait fait remarquer son
manque d'effort et d'intensité pendant
les entraînements et un côté un peu
feignant sur le terrain euh là Woodson
son coach il a il a pas il a pas le même
discours et et il loue un peu le le
sérieux et le travail de Ware sur le
moment et c'est en lien de toute façon
avec je pense la confiance que que W
A vis-à-vis de son son de son
staff comment on imagine après son
premier contrat rooki dans quel genre de
rôle il sera Keler après son à la fin de
son premier contrat rooki
bah
forcément je pense qu'il va essayer de
se nourrir des minutes qu'il aura en
tant que
backup pivot euh moi ça m'étonnerait pas
qu'il aille faire quelques matchs en G
League cont tenu du fait que de son côté
soft et du du travail qu'il a encore à
faire sur de nombreux domaines après
j'espère que ça va pas de le faire lui
faire baisser les bras euh parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a quand même des des
questions qui se posent sur sa mentalité
là il a un staff qui a confiance en lui
mais dans une équipe NBA qui aura pas
forcément la même confiance j'ai peur
qu'on retrouve un peu le joueur qu'on
avait vu à Oregon Lucas tu es tu as les
mêmes craintes ou tu penses que ça va à
terme c'est une question de de
maturation pour
moi le deuxème contrat va se jouer
seulement sur sa capacité de
travail là pour l'instant on a un écho
qui nous dit que il met pas les efforts
en place à l'entraînement et un deuxième
qui nous dit tout le contraire donc je
pense que c'est que les années qui qui h
N qui nous diront ce que ce qu'il en est
vraiment donc je pense que tout dépendra
de ça en tout cas il a beaucoup de
travail ça c'est sûr euh alors
actuellement si il met pas une grosse
charge de travail en place je pense pas
que euh il fera longue carrière dans un
roster NBA ou en tant qu'autre chose que
3è pivot en tout cas pour les plus
anciens moi quand je le vois en fait il
y a un nom qui me vient en tête j'en ai
parlé en off un petit peu au début c'est
le nom de Jali lookafor qui était un peu
annoncé ce rôle de pivot assez près du
cercle que n'est pas kelware mais dans
l'attitude il y avait un petit peu ce
côté-là il dégageit une certaine
nonchalance alors c'est ce qui est
toujours difficile à à voir si c'est une
la vraiment de de la nonchalance ou du
gin fotisme entre guillemets ou si c'est
juste l'attitude du gars qui est qui est
posé et donc ça c'est un peu compliqué à
avoir après on peut aussi se dire que
quelqu'un comme Robert Willams a trouvé
un rôle alors que à la fac CIT pas connu
pour être le plus grand professionnel de
la terre et puis finalement ça ça se
passe bien aussi donc les deux cas de
figure existent euh est-ce qu'on y croit
pour finir à kelware sur du long terme
en NBA du coup Mathias bah moi j'avais
du mal à y croire avant la saison
honnêtement et maintenant quand je vois
une telle progression dans son jeu et
dans ses stats forcément j'y crois un
peu plus maintenant je me pose des
questions sur sur le fait de oui ou non
il va il va maintenir un sérieux et un
travail régulier quoi
Lucas je j'ai le même aveis
mathas le même avis tout le monde est
d'accord c'est merveilleux donc la
réponse sera en juin prochain ainsi se
termine cet épisode sur kellelware
d'Indiana nous on se retrouve très vite
euh vu qu'on est bientôt à la période de
Noël je vous souhaite de très bonnes
fêtes à tous et prenez soin de vous ciao
ciao bye bye
[Musique]
Ciao